Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安。在进入今天的话题之前，我想快速向大家介绍一件令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造属于自己的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）发起的“通往经常性收入挑战”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. How do we talk to children about death?
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有机会赢取由丽莎本人提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）进行一对一辅导的机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的 Linktree 页面“Dr. Marianne Trent”，查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。我们该如何与孩子谈论死亡？
How do we talk to children about death when How do we talk to children about death when the death has arisen as a result of suicide? These are really difficult questions in parenting, but also in mental health. How do we get the tone right? What questions are okay to answer? What questions are okay to ask? How do we phrase things? How do we create a safe space? I am chatting through all of this and more with Caroline Rudehouse in today's episode. I hope you find this so useful. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent, and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. Today's episode is part of our special season, talking about suicide and trying
当死亡是由自杀引起时，我们该如何与孩子谈论死亡？在育儿和心理健康领域，这些都是非常棘手的问题。我们该如何把握语气？哪些问题可以回答？哪些问题可以问？我们该如何措辞？如何创造一个安全的空间？在今天的节目中，我将与卡罗琳·鲁德豪斯（Caroline Rudehouse）一起探讨所有这些问题以及更多内容。希望这对你有所帮助。你好，欢迎收听《有志心理学家播客》（Aspiring Psychologist podcast）。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，我是一名合格的临床心理学家。今天的节目是我们关于自杀的特别系列的一部分，旨在
to normalise conversations surrounding it. This is episode two in our special series of three. They are all separate episodes, but you might well find it helpful to catch the other two if you do have time. So I know you're here because you have questions about how to do this and what is appropriate. So let's dive straight into the episode and I will catch you on the other side. Hi, I just want to welcome along our guest for today, Caroline Rudehouse. Hi, Caroline. Hi, Marianne. Thank you so much for your time in speaking with us.
让围绕自杀的对话常态化。这是我们三集特别系列中的第二集。虽然每一集都是独立的，但如果你有时间，听听另外两集可能会对你有所帮助。我知道你来到这里是因为你有关于如何处理这些问题以及什么是合适做法的疑问。那么，让我们直接进入正题，稍后见。你好，我想欢迎我们今天的嘉宾卡罗琳·鲁德豪斯。你好，卡罗琳。你好，玛丽安。非常感谢你抽出时间与我们交谈。
Just want to firstly say that I was so sorry to learn of the death of your husband and the father of your children thank you I appreciate that did you want to tell us a little bit about him yeah absolutely so I I met Steve in the year 2000 we were set up on a blind date um which I wasn't happy about but then clearly was in the end um and we we hit it off straight away um Steve was quite uh quite a chilled out character which helped balance me out because I'm quite highly strung so we we kind of met in the middle very well but he was um full of energy and kindness and warmth and he had friends all over the world which was very appealing and he
首先，我想说，得知你丈夫、你孩子父亲去世的消息，我感到非常难过。谢谢，我很感激。你想跟我们聊聊他吗？好的，当然。我是在2000年认识史蒂夫（Steve）的。我们是通过相亲认识的，嗯，起初我不太乐意，但最终结果显然很不错。我们一见如故。史蒂夫是一个性格非常随和的人，这正好平衡了我，因为我平时比较紧张，所以我们相处得很好。他充满活力、善良且温暖，他在世界各地都有朋友，这非常有吸引力。他
was very drawn to speed sports motorbikes those sorts of things and he introduced me to to lots of those sorts of things and he had a love for travel as did I so we had a huge amount in common and yeah as I say we hit it off very, very quickly. And we spent a good few years together before we got married in 2005. And then started our kind of family life together beyond that. So in work, Steve worked for a field marketing agency, and his role was to look after teams of people who would was because he was very well known for being an amazing motivational leader and helping a lot of younger people to kind of get onto the career ladder giving all of his time coaching them supporting them encouraging them and being very motivational and inspiring so very much a positive person which again I was drawn to on a personal
非常喜欢速度运动、摩托车之类的东西，他也带我接触了很多这类事物。我们都热爱旅行，所以我们有很多共同点。正如我所说，我们很快就合拍了。我们在2005年结婚前在一起度过了几年美好的时光，之后便开始了我们的家庭生活。在工作方面，史蒂夫在一家现场营销代理公司工作，他的职责是管理团队。他以出色的激励型领导者而闻名，帮助许多年轻人走上职业道路，投入大量时间指导、支持和鼓励他们，非常有动力和启发性。他是一个非常积极的人，这也是我个人所吸引的地方。
level and I guess in later years as we talk about things like spotting signs when somebody's struggling once we'd started to have children I could see that energy reducing and that love for life and for work and for people generally which I put down to just being a knackered parent, really. And all the things that go with lack of sleep and parenting and getting older and those sorts of things. So with hindsight, I can look back and maybe think differently about that now. But yeah, that was Steve. Happy guy for most of the time that I knew him and that we were together thank you and before we started recording you told me that this had really come out of the blue this wasn't a case of of someone with an existing diagnosed depression
我想在后来的几年里，当我们谈论如何发现某人处于困境的迹象时，一旦我们有了孩子，我能感觉到他的那种活力在减退，对生活、工作和人的热爱也在减少，我当时真的以为这只是因为作为父母太累了。加上睡眠不足、育儿以及年龄增长等带来的种种问题。所以事后看来，我现在可能会以不同的眼光看待这件事。但这就是史蒂夫。在我认识他并与他在一起的大部分时间里，他都是个快乐的人。谢谢。在录音开始前，你告诉我这件事发生得非常突然，并不是因为他有已确诊的抑郁症，
or that had kind of evidence that life didn't seem to be worth living this was someone who was hustling out the door in the morning telling you that they'd be picking up your child from Cubs like usual, and they'd see you then. And that's not what happened. Absolutely not. No, I had no idea that Steve was struggling at all. As I said, the energy had reduced in him, but there was no suggestion that he had any mental health difficulties or was considering suicide in any way. So it was the 12th of November 2018. He was starting a new role with a new client through this field marketing agency on that day um we were running around getting ready for for work and I was getting our two young children ready for school and nursery
或者有任何迹象表明他觉得生活不值得留恋。他那天早上还匆匆忙忙地出门，告诉你他会像往常一样去接孩子参加幼童军活动，让你到时候见。但结果却并非如此。绝对不是。不，我完全不知道史蒂夫当时正处于困境中。正如我所说，他的活力确实减退了，但没有任何迹象表明他有心理健康问题，或者有任何自杀的念头。那是2018年11月12日。那天他正通过那家现场营销代理公司开始一份新工作。我们当时正忙着准备上班，我还在给两个年幼的孩子准备上学和去托儿所，
Ada and Evie were nine and two at the time um Steve was getting ready for work even um just before he left for the for the day I had a sore throat which I mentioned to him um and he went flying up the stairs two at a time to grab me some throat sweets from the bathroom cabinet so that um you know just the way he would always be thinking of others and helping and then off he went just confirming that he'd pick Evie up from Cubs on his way home as he always did on a on a Monday evening um and I didn't I didn't give anything a second thought I had no need to until I had a phone call from his work saying that he hadn't arrived it was a about an hour away um so the assumption was that he'd his car had broken down maybe and he was
艾达（Ada）和伊薇（Evie）当时分别是九岁和两岁。史蒂夫也在准备上班。就在他出门前，我提到我喉咙痛，他飞快地跑上楼，从浴室柜里给我拿润喉糖。他总是那样，总是想着别人，乐于助人。然后他就走了，还确认他会在回家的路上顺便去接伊薇参加幼童军活动，就像他每个周一晚上做的那样。我当时根本没多想，直到我接到他公司打来的电话，说他没到岗。那是大约一个小时后的事了。
somewhere by the side of the road with no signal and that's why he hadn't notified anybody but as the day went on and there was no sign of him in the end I had to contact the police and register him as a missing person and that's when I went into full panic mode and that's when the the nightmare really began um the police were kind of not treating it as serious in any way because he had no history of mental health difficulties or no reason to be missing that would suggest he would be coming to any harm um but they they came on the Wednesday morning, two days later. And that's when I heard those 15 words that I'll never forget. And they said to me, we found him.
所以我们假设他的车可能坏了，或者他被困在路边没有信号的地方，所以没能通知任何人。但随着时间推移，他一直没出现，最后我不得不联系警察并将他登记为失踪人口。那时我陷入了彻底的恐慌，噩梦真正开始了。警方起初并没有把这件事看得太严重，因为他没有心理健康问题史，也没有任何理由失踪，这让人觉得他会遭遇不测。但两天后的周三早上，他们来了。我听到了那15个我永远不会忘记的字。他们对我说：我们找到他了。
He's not alive. And it's clear that he's done it to himself. And that's when everything just kind of fell apart. And nothing really made sense ever again after that for me. Yeah. And even, you know, the phrasing of that, it doesn't sound hugely compassionate in terms of thinking about Steve as a person and a human and you as the wife and mother of his children. You know know that's yeah absolutely I had my daughter with me at the time she was two I had friends around me because we've been trying to work out how on earth we were going to try and find him um my mum was there so she broke down and and struggled to take on board that news as well um there wasn't a huge amount of compassion in many of the interactions that I had including things like the inquest for example where they read out
他已经不在了。很明显，他是自杀的。那一刻，一切都崩溃了。从那以后，对我来说，一切都失去了意义。是的。而且，你知道，那种措辞，在考虑到史蒂夫作为一个人和一个生命，以及你作为他的妻子和孩子们的母亲时，听起来并不怎么有同情心。你知道，那确实……是的，绝对是。当时我女儿和我在一起，她才两岁。我身边有朋友，因为我们一直在想方设法寻找他。我妈妈也在场，所以她崩溃了，也很难接受这个消息。
a huge amount of detail about the state of Steve's body when he was found in the back of his car which I had no idea was coming I was given no warning um and there's there's a lot of parts of of this story and different parts of the processes that come after a suicide notifying utilities and the kind of cold computers there's no responses that you get from people despite the circumstances so yeah that there's been a huge amount of moments that have been difficult and could have been made easier. But equally, I've experienced unbelievable compassion from people and from communities and groups of people that I wouldn't necessarily have expected to receive that from. And that's where my focus has had to be in the long run.
在我经历的许多互动中，并没有太多的同情心，包括像死因裁判官调查这样的事情，他们读出了关于史蒂夫被发现时在车后座的身体状况的极其详细的细节，我完全不知道会发生这种情况，我没有得到任何警告。这个故事中有很多部分，以及自杀后处理的各种流程，比如通知公用事业公司，还有那些冷冰冰的电脑，尽管情况特殊，你得到的却只有毫无回应。所以，是的，有很多时刻是非常艰难的，本可以处理得更轻松一些。但同样，我也从那些我未必预料到的人、社区和群体中感受到了难以置信的同情。从长远来看，我必须把重点放在这些地方。
Yeah, absolutely. And I'm just so sorry that that's how you receive the news, probably at your front door, like no real warning or preparation. That's a lot. And that's a lot for you as a grown woman. I'm a mother to two children myself, and I know just how different developmentally a two year old and nine year old are, but how much they need their parents in so many different ways. How did you begin to be able to have those conversations? Probably is a separate question because of the different developmental ages.
是的，绝对是。我真的很抱歉你当时是那样收到消息的，可能就在你家门口，没有任何真正的警告或准备。这太沉重了。作为一个成年女性，这太难承受了。我自己也是两个孩子的母亲，我知道两岁和九岁的孩子在发育阶段有多么不同，但他们以各种不同的方式需要父母。你是如何开始能够进行那些对话的？因为发育年龄的不同，这可能是一个单独的问题。
How did you begin to have that conversation with with the eldest or the youngest absolutely that yeah there's a huge difference between the two and there still is because they're now 15 and 8 and um those gaps still exist massively so it's two different journeys I'm constantly trying to manage for them in those moments directly after I was told by police that Steve had died Ada who was as I say only two I vividly recall seeing her sat at her little white wooden table with her colouring with a police officer sat with her colouring too. And she seemed kind of self-contained. I don't even know if she was aware that there was anything going on. And I didn't have to worry too much about her in that moment. It was Evie, my nine-year-old, that I was desperately concerned about. And things were happening around me that I just wasn't in control of. Somebody from
你是如何开始与大孩子或小孩子进行那次谈话的？绝对是，这两者之间有巨大的差异，现在依然如此，因为她们现在分别是15岁和8岁。这些差距依然巨大，所以我必须时刻为她们管理两段不同的旅程。在警察告诉我史蒂夫去世后的那一刻，我清楚地记得艾达，正如我所说，她才两岁，她坐在白色小木桌旁涂色，一名警察也坐在她旁边陪她涂色。她看起来很平静。我甚至不知道她是否意识到发生了什么。那一刻我不需要太担心她。我非常担心的是我九岁的女儿伊薇。我周围发生的事情让我无法控制。学校的
safeguarding from her school turned up, she was at school at the time, and my best friend Emma contacted the charity Winston's Wish, which was a suggestion from the safeguarding person from school, and they gave her a bit of a script for me to be able to talk to Evie. I had no idea how you deliver news like this, let alone a death, but a death by suicide. She knew that Steve was missing because I'd had to explain it to her after a couple of days, but they had no idea what anything like this would be happening so armed with this kind of script and a few leaflets and pamphlets from this safeguarding person. I arrived at Evie's school and she had a she was standing out the front with the deputy head and she had a big smile on her face when she saw me coming because she,
负责安全的人员出现了，她当时在学校。我最好的朋友艾玛（Emma）联系了“温斯顿的愿望”（Winston's Wish）慈善机构，这是学校安全人员的建议，他们为我提供了一份谈话稿，让我能与伊薇沟通。我根本不知道该如何传达这样的消息，更不用说死亡，还是自杀身亡。她知道史蒂夫失踪了，因为我在几天后不得不向她解释，但她们根本不知道会发生这样的事。带着这份谈话稿和安全人员给的一些传单，我到了伊薇的学校。她和副校长站在前面，看到我来时脸上带着灿烂的笑容，因为她，
that innocence of a child seeing their parents turn up at school. But as we went into the room and she could see my tear-stained face, she knew that it was not going to be good news. And from that moment, I was very clear that I had to be direct and honest and that's the the main advice that Winston's wish had given me and I had to say so it was something along the lines of daddy's been found and he's died and we won't be seeing him again his brain had stopped working properly and this was the beginning of that journey for me with Evie in particular of kind of drip feeding that information over a period of time now for Evie that took probably only a few months from start to finish I'd say that there's kind of these different stages which I can talk about in a moment. For Ada being two, that journey has taken years and just been drawn out across that period of time.
那是孩子看到父母出现在学校时的天真。但当我们走进房间，她看到我满脸泪痕时，她就知道不会是什么好消息了。从那一刻起，我非常清楚我必须直接和诚实，这是“温斯顿的愿望”给我的主要建议。我不得不说，大概是这样的内容：爸爸被找到了，他已经去世了，我们再也见不到他了，他的大脑停止了正常工作。这对我来说，特别是对伊薇来说，是那个旅程的开始，即在一段时间内慢慢地传达这些信息。对于伊薇来说，从开始到结束可能只用了几个月。我想说，有几个不同的阶段，我稍后可以谈谈。对于两岁的艾达来说，那个旅程持续了几年，并一直延伸到那段时间里。
So that that first step of saying that Steve had died and he wouldn't be coming back was what I had to explain. And then it's kind of talking in terms that they would understand that it was something that daddy had done to himself. Evie had a very good understanding of mental health, thanks to conversations at school and learning that they do in PSHE sessions and those sorts of things. The next thing I had to do was talk about kind of why he may have done that. And we talked about mental health issues and people being unhappy and not knowing how to deal with that unhappiness or how to talk to other people about it. It was very early on that Evie asked me how he'd done it, which was the hardest conversation I've ever had to have with her, harder than telling her that he'd died, because
所以，说出史蒂夫已经去世且不会再回来的第一步，是我必须解释的。然后，要用她们能理解的语言谈论这是爸爸对自己做的事情。多亏了学校的对话以及她们在个人、社会、健康与经济教育（PSHE）课程中学到的知识，伊薇对心理健康有很好的理解。我接下来要做的是谈论他为什么会那样做。我们谈到了心理健康问题，谈到了人们感到不快乐，以及不知道如何处理这种不快乐或如何与他人谈论它。伊薇很早就问我他是怎么做的，这是我不得不与她进行的有史以来最艰难的谈话，比告诉她他去世了还要难，因为
it felt like such a brutal thing to have to explain. Steve had suffocated himself with a plastic bag in his car. And to have to say that to a nine-year-old was horrific. But again, the advice from Winston's wish was when they ask, they're ready to know. And it's our responsibility as parents to deliver that news in the most considered and compassionate way and using language that they would understand. And that's what I was intent on doing whenever I needed to. So that whole kind of process with Evie, as I say, was done over the course of a few months. I'm still working on that process with Ada. We haven't got to the point yet where I've
解释这件事感觉太残忍了。史蒂夫在车里用塑料袋窒息了自己。不得不对一个九岁的孩子说出这些话是可怕的。但同样，“温斯顿的愿望”的建议是：当她们问的时候，她们就准备好知道了。作为父母，我们有责任以最体贴和富有同情心的方式，并使用她们能理解的语言来传达这些消息。这就是我打算在需要时所做的。所以，正如我所说，与伊薇的整个过程是在几个月内完成的。我还在处理与艾达的过程。我们还没有到那一步，我还没有
explained to her what he actually did because she hasn't shown any need to know that information yet what she does know is her own understanding of mental health difficulties and how they can be so great that somebody can choose to take their own life or see that as the only option at least. She has said to me, there was one moment where I was walking her to school one morning and she came out with this really profound statement and she said it was something along the lines of men don't cry and they don't grieve and they really should because if they don't and they don't let the emotions out they can die and whilst it was a shocking thing to hear on the way to school when it wasn't the normal conversations that we would have it did give me a really good insight into how she was understanding
向她解释他到底做了什么，因为她还没有表现出需要知道这些信息的迹象。她所知道的是她自己对心理健康困难的理解，以及这些困难如何变得如此巨大，以至于一个人可以选择结束自己的生命，或者至少将其视为唯一的选择。她曾对我说过，有一次我早上送她上学，她突然说出了一句非常深刻的话，她说大概是这样的：男人不哭，他们不悲伤，但他们真的应该哭，因为如果他们不这样做，不把情绪发泄出来，他们可能会死。虽然在去学校的路上听到这些令人震惊，而且这不是我们通常会进行的对话，但这确实让我很好地洞察了她是如何理解
the conversations that we'd been having, not just between her and I, but also between Evie and her as well, and the three of us. And it was only actually the other day where she'd been hearing, when she hears the word suicide, it does prompt her to ask questions and start to get curious, as children do. She's eight years old. And she said to me the other day, Mummy, I don't want to know today, but at some point soon, will you tell me how Daddy died? And I said, absolutely, of course I will.
我们一直在进行的对话，不仅是我和她之间的，还有伊薇和她之间的，以及我们三个人的。其实就在前几天，当她听到“自杀”这个词时，这确实促使她像孩子们一样开始提问并产生好奇心。她八岁了。前几天她对我说：“妈妈，我今天不想知道，但不久后的某个时候，你能告诉我爸爸是怎么死的吗？”我说：“当然，我一定会告诉你的。”
And then she went off back to her swing or her game that she was playing. And that was it. And I think I'm then left in tears. And as I have been over the course of many years on that day where she came up to me and said, for my birthday, could I have my daddy back? And I'm I don't know what to say, it's overwhelming. And then 10 seconds later, she says, actually, no, I want a unicorn. And I, I'm still crying an hour later, because of that initial thing that she's asked for that I can't give her, but she's moved on. And again, over, over the years, I've learned how both my children have received this information in different ways and then processed it in their own different ways Evie's much more of a deep
然后她就回去玩她的秋千或游戏了。就是这样。然后我就会泪流满面。就像多年来在那一天一样，她走到我面前说：“生日那天，我能要回我的爸爸吗？”我不知道该说什么，这太让人难以承受了。然后10秒钟后，她说：“其实不用了，我想要一只独角兽。”一个小时后我还在哭，因为她最初要求的那个我无法给她，但她已经走出来了。同样，多年来，我了解到我的两个孩子是如何以不同的方式接收这些信息，并以她们各自不同的方式处理这些信息的。伊薇是一个更深沉的
thinker she's a teenager she she has a much greater understanding of that permanence of loss and those sorts of things so yeah there's a there's a huge difference between the two of them, but there is this process that I've come back to time and time again of the different stages that are involved. Absolutely. Such powerful words you've shared with us. And I think I would just echo what you've said really about how quickly children can get full up and they will take away their little nugget that they've got from you. They will go away and digest that, maybe even across a few sleeps,
思考者，她是个青少年，她对失去的永久性有更深刻的理解，诸如此类。所以，是的，她们两人之间有巨大的差异，但我一次又一次地回到这个过程，即所涉及的不同阶段。绝对是。你与我们分享的话语太有力量了。我想我只想附和你所说的，关于孩子们能多快地感到满足，她们会从你那里拿走她们得到的一小块信息。她们会走开去消化它，甚至可能跨越几次睡眠，
a few days, a few weeks. And then they'll come back to you when you're chopping some cucumber or something and come back to it again, ready for the next installment. And I think it's what you've demonstrated so nicely is always holding that open space of being willing to go where they need to, but stopping where they are at. So, you know, you could have said, sure, I'll tell you now, but that's not what she wanted. She very
几天，几周。然后当你在切黄瓜或做其他事情时，她们会回来，准备好接受下一部分。我认为你展示得非常好的一点是，始终保持开放的空间，愿意去她们需要去的地方，但在她们停留的地方停下来。所以，你知道，你本可以说：“当然，我现在就告诉你。”但那不是她想要的。她非常
quickly communicated and clearly communicated, I might be ready, I'm intrigued, but I want to know that that's within my control and that you, I guess, can manage that. Because as they get older, they think about our own kind of looking after us, don't they? And making sure that we're OK and kind of modelling back some of that parenting they've had from us. That's a really important point. Both of them are empaths, so compassionate, so caring about other people, particularly me. And they will often avoid saying something or asking something because they don't want to upset me. And I'm constantly reminding them that grief is sad. We can't get away from
迅速且清晰地传达了：“我可能准备好了，我很好奇，但我希望知道这在我的控制范围内，而且我猜，你能处理好。”因为随着她们长大，她们会考虑我们照顾她们的方式，不是吗？确保我们没问题，并模仿她们从我们这里得到的一些育儿方式。这是一个非常重要的点。她们俩都是共情者，非常富有同情心，非常关心他人，尤其是关心我。她们经常会避免说些什么或问些什么，因为她们不想让我难过。我不断提醒她们，悲伤是难过的。我们无法逃避
that. It will be upsetting to have these conversations and we will move on afterwards and we will experience joy again and we will do all the things that make us happy but we have to have these conversations and we have to accept grief and we have to work through it together and I recall a really key point as well about trust as well that um I've I've come across so many people from the experiences and conversations I've had where they've lost a parent many decades ago and it was pushed under the carpet and they were told that it was a car accident or you know cancer or something because of the shame surrounding suicide and the difficult conversations that people would much rather avoid having. But then sometime later in life,
这一点。进行这些对话会让人难过，但之后我们会继续前进，我们会再次体验快乐，我们会做所有让我们快乐的事情，但我们必须进行这些对话，我们必须接受悲伤，我们必须一起克服它。我也记得关于信任的一个非常关键的点，即……在我的经历和对话中，我遇到过很多人，他们在几十年前失去了父母，当时这件事被掩盖了，他们被告知那是车祸，或者是癌症之类的，因为围绕自杀的羞耻感以及人们宁愿避免进行的艰难对话。但后来在生活中的某个时候，
they've discovered the truth and that's completely shattered the trust that they have with those family members that could have been honest with them at the time. And the idea of that truth, that trust being lost between us just terrifies me um much more so than having to have honest conversations with them right now that they they seem to take on board unbelievably well um and I've had to learn this as a skill I've had to learn so many different elements of of this and know that I can be honest with them and that they will be okay. And they're growing and thriving and becoming more and more resilient with every conversation that we have and every challenge that they face. So I try to see these as opportunities to learn
他们发现了真相，这完全粉碎了他们与那些本可以在当时对他们诚实的家庭成员之间的信任。那种真相、那种信任被破坏的想法让我感到恐惧……远比现在必须与她们进行诚实的对话要可怕得多，她们似乎接受得非常好。我必须把这作为一种技能来学习，我必须学习这方面的许多不同要素，并知道我可以对她们诚实，她们会没事的。她们正在成长、茁壮成长，并且随着我们进行的每一次对话和她们面临的每一个挑战，变得越来越有韧性。所以我试着把这些看作是学习的机会，
and grow and get stronger, even though they're really sad. sad yeah and I think with the sadness um so my dad died in 2017 when my I think our youngest of very similar ages so he's just turned eight in June um so he was 18 months when my dad died and my eldest was four years old so neither of them actually remember my dad I don't't think. But, you know, I've always been clear that if they want to talk to me about him, and I cry, it isn't them that's made me cry, you know, it's the fact that I really, really loved him, I cared about him. And, you know, when we love someone, we might get upset upset but it's always okay to have those conversations even if it makes me cry does that make sense absolutely and and yeah we're exactly
成长并变得更强大，即使它们真的很令人难过。难过，是的。我想关于悲伤……我爸爸在2017年去世了，当时我的……我想我们最小的孩子年龄非常相近，所以他今年6月刚满八岁。所以当我爸爸去世时他才18个月大，而我的大孩子四岁。所以她们俩其实都不记得我爸爸了，我想。但是，你知道，我一直很明确，如果她们想和我谈论他，而我哭了，那并不是她们让我哭的，你知道，这是因为我真的、真的很爱他，我很在乎他。而且，你知道，当我们爱一个人时，我们可能会难过，但即使这让我哭泣，进行这些对话也总是可以的，这有道理吗？绝对是，而且是的，我们完全
the same I think they they would avoid at all costs anything that would upset me but I've had to keep on making that point that like you've, it's not you that's upsetting me. It's a sad thing when someone dies and you'll experience it again and again, unfortunately, as life goes on. So we can't avoid these conversations and we can't avoid being sad. But that equally means if we did try and avoid them, we never talk about that person um and we can't do that either so there's never going to be an ideal solution we can't take the pain away and have these conversations so we have to work through it in the best way that we can and I think that's where we've reached between the three of us yeah absolutely and I think one of the differences with suicide so in the grief
一样。我想她们会不惜一切代价避免任何让我难过的事情，但我不得不一直强调这一点，就像你所说的，让你难过的不是她们。当有人去世时，这是一件令人难过的事情，不幸的是，随着生活的继续，你会一次又一次地经历它。所以我们不能避免这些对话，我们不能避免悲伤。但这同样意味着，如果我们试图避免它们，我们就永远不会谈论那个人，我们也不能那样做。所以永远不会有一个理想的解决方案，我们无法消除痛苦并进行这些对话，所以我们必须以我们能做到的最好方式去克服它。我想这就是我们三个人之间达成的共识。是的，绝对是。我想自杀的一个不同之处在于，在悲伤
collective somebody talks about suicide as being like pouring acid on the wounds of grief because it kind of amplifies everything and it also takes away the opportunity to do some of the things that I recommend with children if you have got someone who's very unwell and a death is expected that actually when you when they're super young you sit and watch the bing bunny butterfly episode for example and that you start to as you're walking along and you see a dead mouse or a dead pigeon or a dead insect that you start to stop and take a look and actually think about the processes involved with a death and that it's permanent and that we don't come back that it's not like the cartoons we're not magically reappearing and I think what you lose with a suicide as well is so much of that preparation that you you're
集体中，有人谈论自杀就像是在悲伤的伤口上泼酸，因为它放大了所有的一切。它也剥夺了做一些我向孩子们推荐的事情的机会，如果你有一个病得很重且预期会死亡的人，实际上当她们非常年幼时，你们坐在一起看《小兔邦邦》（Bing Bunny）的蝴蝶那一集，例如，当你走着看到一只死老鼠、死鸽子或死昆虫时，你开始停下来看一看，实际上思考一下死亡所涉及的过程，它是永久的，我们不会回来，它不像卡通片，我们不会神奇地重新出现。我认为你在自杀中失去的也是很多那种准备，你
not mentioning perhaps I didn't mention that grumpy was going to die but I'm making sure that my children have a developmental understanding of death. And I'm not using words like poorly, because then when I say, oh, baby, are you feeling poorly? They then begin to think, gosh, I'm going to die. You know, we're being, like you said, quite matter of fact with our words and and leaving them space to talk and to be curious and I think that's so important but it's then trying to kind of retrofit that in a suicide which is so so extra extra challenging absolutely I think like like you said at the start there I've heard suicide described as grief with the volume turned up and it absolutely is and the different extra emotions and challenges that it brings. But yeah,
没有提到，也许我没有提到格伦皮（Grumpy）会死，但我确保我的孩子们对死亡有发育上的理解。我没有使用“不舒服”（poorly）这样的词，因为当我后来问：“哦，宝贝，你感觉不舒服吗？”她们就会开始想：“天哪，我要死了。”你知道，我们就像你说的，用词非常客观，给她们留出空间去交谈和好奇，我认为这非常重要。但试图在自杀事件中进行这种事后补救，是非常、非常具有挑战性的。绝对是，我想就像你开头说的那样，我听过人们将自杀描述为“音量调大的悲伤”，它确实如此，它带来了额外的不同情绪和挑战。但是的，
you don't have that opportunity to prepare. But I guess that's the same with sudden accidents and those sorts of things as well. And I think perhaps it's a responsibility for us as parents to consider this at some point anyway. I mean, Evie in particular had experienced the loss of several grandparents. So she was conscious of the concept of death and people no longer being around, but nobody as close as her dad. So yeah, it was very much a retrofit. And it's those conversations afterwards that lead more into topics like mental health and self-care and taking care of ourselves so we don't end up in a similar position. I think one of the other complications with suicide is those statistics around people who have lost a loved one to suicide are more susceptible to mental health issues themselves and ultimately taking their own lives
你没有那种准备的机会。但我猜这对于突发事故之类的也是一样的。我认为也许作为父母，我们在某个时候考虑这一点是我们的责任。我的意思是，伊薇特别经历过几位祖父母的离世。所以她意识到死亡的概念以及人们不再存在，但没有人像她爸爸那样亲近。所以，是的，这很大程度上是一种事后补救。而正是那些随后的对话，更多地引导到了心理健康、自我保健和照顾好自己等话题上，这样我们就不会陷入类似的境地。我认为自杀的另一个复杂之处在于，关于那些失去亲人自杀的人更容易患上心理健康问题，并最终结束自己的生命，
or at least considering it and and so are their children there's studies to suggest that children who've lost a parent to suicide are three times more likely to take their own lives at some point. And these statistics terrify me. So rather than talking about the death quite so much, we talk about the need to take care of ourselves in an age appropriate way. And they do things like this at school as well. But yeah, we're constantly talking about needing to make sure we're being gentle with ourselves and being conscious of our emotions and all of those sorts of things, which I don't think I would have considered had this not happened. And I think if I'm desperately scrabbling around for a silver lining here, it's that
或者至少考虑过自杀的统计数据，她们的孩子也是如此。有研究表明，失去父母自杀的孩子在某个时候结束自己生命的可能性要高出三倍。这些统计数据让我感到恐惧。所以与其过多地谈论死亡，我们谈论的是以适合年龄的方式照顾好自己的必要性。她们在学校也做这些事情。但是的，我们一直在谈论需要确保我们对自己温柔，并意识到我们的情绪以及所有这些事情，如果这件事没有发生，我想我不会考虑这些。我想如果我在这里拼命寻找一线希望的话，那就是
fact that both my children are very conscious of the dangers of um poor mental health and poor well-being poor physical well-being all those sorts of things and the the absolute paramount need to take our take look after ourselves and and look after one another Evie has since become a mental health ambassador at school and she goes talking to um primary schools and assemblies and things as part of this role to younger children on the subject of mental health and how we should be looking after ourselves and that I don't think is something that she would have done had this not happened um so yeah there's so proud of her and what she's creating i know you shared um a little short film with me that she'd been part of making as well and it was
事实是，我的两个孩子都非常意识到心理健康不佳、身体健康不佳等所有这些事情的危险，以及照顾好自己和照顾彼此的至高无上的必要性。伊薇后来成为了学校的心理健康大使，作为这个角色的一部分，她去向小学和集会等地方的年幼孩子谈论心理健康以及我们应该如何照顾自己。如果这件事没有发生，我想她不会做这些事情。所以，是的，我为她和她所创造的一切感到骄傲。我知道你和我分享了一部她参与制作的小短片，它
so incredibly powerful you know it's shaping these little young lives but hopefully in a way that feels like it's building them as well absolutely yeah and and that that resilience um because the world's a tough place at times as as we know and unfortunately it's something they need to know too but yeah the the um animation that Evie uh was part of um creating was was sort of came about from some challenges she was having when she first started at senior school when she was 11 and she would hear people kind of laughing and joking about the topic of suicide saying you know I'll kill myself if I've got to sit through another lesson like that or kids would use that acronym KYS when they're messaging each other suggesting
非常震撼。你知道，它正在塑造这些年轻的小生命，但希望是以一种感觉也在建立她们的方式。绝对是，是的，那种韧性……因为正如我们所知，世界有时是一个艰难的地方，不幸的是，这也是她们需要知道的事情。但是的，伊薇参与创作的那部动画，是因为她在11岁刚上中学时遇到的一些挑战。她会听到人们在谈论自杀话题时开玩笑，说：“如果我必须再上一节那样的课，我就自杀。”或者孩子们在互相发信息时会使用“KYS”（Kill Yourself，去死吧）这个缩写，暗示
they should you know kill yourself when they've done something embarrassing, which is horrendous, and it would be so upsetting for her. So she wrote a story about it. And she was really brave, and she approached the head of year at the school she was at at the time, and shared this story with them and they read it out at an assembly unfortunately it didn't have any impact at all and I think there were other elements of this school that we weren't too keen on when we when we first spoke to them about her going there and the extra support that she might need and they talked about all of the different facilities that they have to to kind of safeguard children and all the
当她们做了尴尬的事情时，对方应该去死，这太可怕了，这对她来说会非常令人难过。所以她写了一个关于这个的故事。她非常勇敢，她联系了当时所在学校的年级主任，并与他们分享了这个故事，他们在集会上读了出来。不幸的是，这没有任何影响。我想当我们第一次和他们谈论她去那里上学以及她可能需要的额外支持时，我们对这所学校的其他方面并不是很看好。他们谈到了他们拥有的所有不同设施，以保护儿童，以及他们拥有的所有
well-being facilities that they have didn't seem to um pan out it felt like there was perhaps a little bit of lip service there so anyway this this story didn't land as Evie had hoped um and I mentioned that to some of my colleagues at work I work for a creative agency where there's some very clever animators and illustrators and they took Evie's story and turned it into a beautiful animation with stunning illustration and music and it was there was a voiceover recorded for it as well um and while they while that was being done Evie was finding this school more and more of a challenge for various reasons and I moved her to a different school where she immediately began to thrive and this is where she became a mental health ambassador and started just getting stuck into all of these different roles
心理健康设施，似乎并没有奏效。感觉那里可能只是口头上的支持。所以，无论如何，这个故事并没有像伊薇希望的那样产生影响。我向我工作中的一些同事提到了这一点，我在一家创意代理公司工作，那里有一些非常聪明的动画师和插画家，他们采用了伊薇的故事，并将其制作成了一部美丽的动画，配有令人惊叹的插图和音乐，还录制了旁白。在制作过程中，伊薇因为各种原因发现这所学校越来越具有挑战性，我把她转到了另一所学校，她在那里立即开始茁壮成长。这就是她成为心理健康大使并开始投入所有这些不同角色的地方。
there's an amazing well-being center where she can go at any point during the day and feel that sense of safety around her with people that she knows and trusts whether that's teachers or fellow students and I think from the very top from the senior leadership at the school, from the head down, they take it seriously. The whole subject of emotional well-being and mental health. It's built into everything that they they do, everything that they teach. And it's certainly not any there's no lip service there whatsoever so um Evie has now introduced the animation to this school and had an amazing response to it I've shared it um on my social channels and it's now being shown across the country um that's in schools um in assemblies it's being added to the curriculums
那里有一个很棒的心理健康中心，她可以在一天中的任何时候去那里，并在她认识和信任的人身边感受到那种安全感，无论是老师还是同学。我认为从学校的高层领导，从校长开始，他们都非常认真地对待这件事。整个关于情感健康和心理健康的主题。它融入了他们所做的一切，他们所教的一切。那里绝对没有任何口头上的支持。所以，伊薇现在已经把这部动画介绍给了这所学校，并得到了惊人的反响。我在我的社交频道上分享了它，它现在正在全国范围内播放，
of different schools across the country but But there's also other settings and environments that are using it. So the NHS have built it into their nursing inductions in certain hospital trusts, different grief charities are using it. Mental health first aiders are using it in workplaces and line managers are using it with their training and those sorts of things. And it's all around this kind of sensitivity of language on the subject of suicide, whether that's for a child or for an adult. And that I am ridiculously proud of, with Evie being the instigator of this
在学校里，在集会上，它正在被添加到全国不同学校的课程中。但也有其他环境和场所正在使用它。例如，英国国家医疗服务体系（NHS）已将其纳入某些医院信托机构的护理入职培训中，不同的悲伤慈善机构正在使用它。心理健康急救员在工作场所使用它，直线经理在培训中使用它，诸如此类。这一切都围绕着在自杀话题上语言的敏感性，无论是对孩子还是对成年人。对此，我感到无比自豪，伊薇是这一切的推动者，
and the one that made all that happen. Words. with Evie being the instigator of this and the one that made all that happen. Words. They can tumble out. As quiet as a whisper. Or as loud as a shout. Words. They can be mean. Hurtful comments or messages on a screen.
也是让这一切发生的人。文字。它们可以像耳语一样悄悄溜走。或者像呐喊一样响亮。文字。它们可以是刻薄的。屏幕上伤人的评论或信息。
Words. They can make us cry. Especially when a loved one has died through suicide. Here's a letter full of words, written by a girl whose dad is now a blackbird. There was a time when I had two parents. I was young and I was confident that was the way life would be for us. But one day I got pulled out of class and saw my mum walking towards the school with my godmother. I was confused when I saw my mum's tear-stained face. She told me that my dad hadn't shown up for work and before anyone realized he was missing, he had died by suicide. This was the biggest shock of our lives. He had seemed pretty happy with life and had never mentioned feeling depressed, so it took months for me to even accept what had happened.
文字。它们可以让我们哭泣。尤其是当亲人因自杀而去世时。这是一封充满文字的信，由一个爸爸现在变成了一只黑鸟的女孩所写。曾经有一段时间，我有两个父母。我当时很年轻，我很确信这就是我们生活的方式。但有一天，我被叫出教室，看到我妈妈和我的教母一起向学校走来。当我看到妈妈满脸泪痕时，我很困惑。她告诉我，爸爸没有去上班，在任何人意识到他失踪之前，他就已经自杀身亡了。这是我们一生中最大的打击。他看起来对生活很满意，从未提到过感到抑郁，所以我花了几个月的时间才接受发生了什么。
It took many more after that, for me to stop feeling guilty, every time I listened to the songs he liked to sing along to. I've missed out on summer holidays at the beach with him. I've missed out on having him in the audience at school shows. We've all missed out. So has Dad. I'm telling you this because I've heard jokes about suicide and depression at school. And this has really hurt me.
在那之后又过了很久，我才停止在每次听到他喜欢唱的歌时感到内疚。我错过了和他一起在海滩度过的暑假。我错过了他在学校演出时坐在观众席中。我们都错过了。爸爸也错过了。我告诉你这些是因为我在学校听到过关于自杀和抑郁的笑话。这真的伤害了我。
Take it from me, suicide isn't funny. It's not something to laugh and joke about. You may not know it, but your words can really upset people who have been affected by suicide. It's tough, you know, to hear people laughing about something that completely turned my world upside down. My dad died a few years ago now, but the memories of what happened are still a huge part of my daily life. Words matter. So think before you speak. Please make kindness a promise that you keep. keep oh amazing as a mummy a fellow human it just brings shivers down my spine it's amazing stuff and i just wanted to talk to your fear really so speaking as a qualified clinical psychologist who specializes in complex trauma and grief I would say that the the stats for increased probability
听我说，自杀绝不是一件好笑的事。这不是可以拿来开玩笑的事情。你可能不知道，你的言语真的会伤害到那些受自杀影响的人。你知道，听到别人拿彻底颠覆我世界的事情开玩笑，这真的很难受。我父亲几年前去世了，但关于那件事的记忆至今仍是我日常生活的重要组成部分。言语很重要。所以说话前请三思。请把善良当作你信守的承诺。这太令人惊叹了，作为一个母亲，一个同类，这让我不寒而栗，这太棒了。我真的想谈谈你的恐惧，作为一名专门研究复杂创伤和悲伤的合格临床心理学家，我想说，家庭成员自杀导致其亲属自杀概率增加的统计数据
of someone ending their own life when it's been in their family is probably going to be in families where it's been shame-filled and not spoken about and where they've not been able to really express their emotions and ask questions without fear of the reaction the response or that they might be in trouble and I think that what I know about mitigating factors you are doing in abundance and what we know is it's the difference, being the difference that makes the difference for children and always knowing that they've got that safe space that's non-judgmental, that's compassionate, that they can bring their best selves to, but also their worst selves. And I often think with my children, you know, I will always love you. I don't always
可能更多出现在那些充满羞耻感、避而不谈，且无法真正表达情感、不敢在担心反应或惹麻烦的情况下提出问题的家庭中。我认为你所做的缓解因素非常充足。我们知道，对孩子而言，成为那个带来改变的人，让他们始终知道有一个非评判性、充满同情心的安全空间，让他们能够展现最好的自己，也能展现最糟糕的自己，这才是最重要的。我常对我的孩子们说，我永远爱你们。我不总是
like your behavior, but you can always talk to me whatever you're worried about and that mitigates so much to to the extent where I would say it mitigates it to kind of minimal um so I don't know if that's useful at own father took his life it could almost normalize it to a point where it becomes an option for them or they believe that it's an option for me if i'm having a bad day or i'm reacting badly to something that's happened or I'm upset about something and I I've worked very hard and researched a huge amount on how to to mitigate that we can never remove it completely because it's suicide is something that exists one way or another but I'm almost hopeful that through the experience we've had we can go the other way and we can learn that suicide yes it might be an option but there are a huge number of other things that we can look into doing that we are much more
喜欢你们的行为，但无论你们担心什么，都可以随时跟我说。这在很大程度上缓解了问题，甚至可以说缓解到了最低限度。所以我不知道这是否有用。如果父亲自杀，这几乎会使自杀正常化，让它成为一种选择，或者让他们认为如果我度过了糟糕的一天，或者对发生的事情反应不好，或者对某事感到难过，这也是一种选择。我非常努力地工作，并研究了大量如何缓解这种情况的方法。我们永远无法完全消除它，因为自杀无论如何都是存在的，但我几乎怀着希望，通过我们的经历，我们可以走向另一个方向，我们可以认识到，自杀确实可能是一种选择，但我们还可以考虑做很多其他事情，我们现在作为一个家庭
conscious and aware of as a family now that we otherwise wouldn't have been um wouldn't have known about so yeah I'm hopeful that it's always okay to ask for help always yes absolutely um and I think that there's there's a lot of people around well I wouldn't say there's a lot of people I mean there's a few people around me that reinforce that message um my best friend for example who is the girl's godmother checks in in with them regularly and she'll do it in a way that works for them. So she'll send them a WhatsApp or, you know, see that they've been on Instagram recently or Evie has at least and send something funny to her or something that relates to a conversation we might have had. So we're kind of learning to operate on their level as well and have these conversations that they can relate to without turning into like embarrassing parent mode and trying to use language that just wouldn't work. So yeah, it's, it's,
更加清醒和意识到这一点，否则我们可能不会知道。所以是的，我希望人们知道寻求帮助永远是可以的。是的，绝对是。我想我周围有很多……嗯，我不会说很多人，但我周围有几个人在强化这个信息。比如我最好的朋友，也就是孩子们的教母，她会定期查看她们的情况，而且她会用适合她们的方式。她会给她们发WhatsApp，或者看到她们最近上了Instagram（至少Evie是这样），然后发一些有趣的东西给她们，或者与我们可能谈论过的话题相关的内容。所以我们也在学习在她们的层面进行交流，进行她们能产生共鸣的对话，而不是变成那种尴尬的家长模式，试图使用根本行不通的语言。所以是的，这是，这是，
it's a constant journey that I'm on and I'm, I'm lucky to have support from a few good people with too. Yeah, I'm so pleased to hear that you're's a very special thing to me so um I'm not particularly religious I don't believe in in reincarnation but I I'm open-minded about about the whole concept um and shortly after Steve died there was a a little boy blackbird that would always be in the back garden um and I'd started to notice that he would kind of hop right up to the back door um which was unusual um but I you know I was too busy thinking about other things to to think much of that but there were times when I'd think back to how Steve would talk about his mum and some of the beliefs that she had around kind of an older relative who had died and maybe had come back to visit as a bird or something. And my mum, again, not particularly into things like reincarnation, but when she'd see a butterfly, it would make her think of her mum and bring her some comfort so I started to look at this blackbird that was hobbling around the garden all the time
这是一段我正在经历的持续旅程，我很幸运能得到几个好人的支持。是的，听到这些我很高兴。这对我来说是一件非常特别的事情。我不是特别信教，我不相信轮回，但我对整个概念持开放态度。Steve去世后不久，后花园里总有一只小黑鸟。我开始注意到它会一直跳到后门，这很不寻常。但我当时太忙了，满脑子都是别的事，没怎么在意。但有时我会回想起Steve是如何谈论他妈妈的，以及她关于一位已故长辈可能化身为鸟回来探望的信仰。我妈妈也不太相信轮回之类的东西，但当她看到蝴蝶时，会让她想起她妈妈，并给她带来一些安慰。所以我开始关注这只一直在花园里蹒跚学步的黑鸟，
um and for some reason I started referring to him as daddy blackbird and I'd call the girls over and say look daddy blackbird's come to visit it almost felt like something nice to just say in amongst all the horror and sorrow. And they'd get quite excited to see him. And there were times when I'd be a bit pissed off when he turned up because I was busy washing up and doing all the millions of jobs that Steve would have been doing had he been there. And instead, that's potentially him hopping around and flying around free as a bird. But no, over time, I sort of developed this odd relationship where I'd be happy to see him in the back garden and I'd feel a sense of comfort when I did.
出于某种原因，我开始称它为“黑鸟爸爸”，我会把孩子们叫过来，说看，黑鸟爸爸来看我们了。在所有的恐惧和悲伤中，这感觉像是一件美好的事情。她们看到它会很兴奋。有时当它出现时，我会有点恼火，因为我正忙着洗碗，做着如果Steve还在的话他本该做的数百万件家务。而这只鸟可能是他，像鸟儿一样自由地跳来跳去、飞来飞去。但随着时间的推移，我建立了一种奇怪的关系，看到它在后花园出现我会感到高兴，看到它时我会感到一种安慰。
And I was able to bring him into conversation with the girls as well. And then there were long periods of time where we wouldn't see him, but he always seems to come back. I'm not sure if it's the same blackbird but it doesn't really bother me either way it's more around what it symbolizes and on his first on Steve's first birthday after he died we went to a garden center and we bought a china blackbird to put in the garden to fill those gaps when the real daddy blackbird isn't around. Meanwhile, I'd been kind of starting to write about my experiences just to get it out of my head and onto a piece of paper because writing is a passion for me. And I realised when I looked at what I'd written, it was almost like a series of chapters. And then I realised that a series of chapters actually sort of represents a book. And all of a sudden, when people were
我也能把它带入与孩子们的谈话中。有时会有很长一段时间看不到它，但它似乎总会回来。我不确定是不是同一只黑鸟，但这对我来说并不重要，这更多是关于它象征着什么。在Steve去世后的第一个生日，我们去了一家园艺中心，买了一只瓷黑鸟放在花园里，以填补真正的“黑鸟爸爸”不在时的空缺。与此同时，我开始写下我的经历，只是为了把它从脑海中清理出来，写在纸上，因为写作是我的爱好。当我审视我写的东西时，我意识到它几乎是一系列章节。然后我意识到一系列章节实际上代表了一本书。突然间，当人们
saying to me, you should write a book about everything you've been through, I thought, oh, I think I have, or at least I've started to. So I continued with that. and there seemed to be only one title that I could give this book and it was Daddy Blackbird and it's in three sections it talks about the history of how we first got together and some of the amazing adventures that we had together as well as some of the challenges that we faced together. It talks about the horror, obviously, when Steve died and all the things that came after that. And then the third section is about the hope and all of the lessons that I've learned that I want to share with other people, particularly people in a position like me. And I've broken that down into three different sections.
对我说，你应该把你经历的一切写成一本书时，我想，哦，我想我已经写了，或者至少我已经开始了。所以我继续写下去。这本书似乎只有一个标题，那就是《黑鸟爸爸》。它分为三个部分，讲述了我们最初是如何走到一起的，我们一起经历的一些奇妙冒险，以及我们共同面对的一些挑战。它讲述了Steve去世时的恐怖，以及之后发生的一切。第三部分是关于希望，以及我学到的所有我想与他人分享的经验教训，特别是那些处境和我相似的人。我把它分成了三个不同的部分。
And it's what I call my triangle of recovery. So I talk about the power of me and how I've drawn on the strengths I had already, but also developed new strengths and skills. Then there's the power of my children, which I've spoken about in depth and taking strength from seeing their resilience grow and thrive and all the amazing things that they're achieving. And then the last part of that is the power of my community and the people around me that have supported me from day one, but also the new connections and relationships I've built in more recent times.
这就是我所说的“康复三角”。我谈到了“我的力量”，以及我如何利用我已有的优势，同时也发展了新的优势和技能。然后是“我孩子们的力量”，我深入谈过这一点，从看到她们的韧性成长和茁壮成长，以及她们取得的所有惊人成就中汲取力量。最后一部分是“我社区的力量”，那些从第一天起就支持我的人，以及我最近建立的新联系和关系。
And yeah, Daddy Blackbird is now a very special thing to me, not just the actual bird that visits every day in the garden, but the book that I've almost completed now. Well it sounds like it's a great read is that aimed at adults would you say? Yes I would say it is aimed at adults mainly as I say for people that have been through what I have but I've found in sharing all my different experiences and stories and the little anecdotes that help people understand what it's like to lose somebody to suicide. I think I've had so many people contact me to say that it's helped them get
是的，《黑鸟爸爸》现在对我来说是一件非常特别的事情，不仅仅是每天在花园里造访的那只鸟，还有我现在几乎完成的那本书。听起来这是一本很棒的书，你是针对成年人写的吗？是的，我想它主要是针对成年人的，正如我所说，是为那些经历过我所经历的事情的人写的。但在分享我所有不同的经历、故事和那些帮助人们理解失去亲人于自杀是什么感觉的小轶事时，我发现有很多人联系我，说它帮助他们度过了
through a difficult period where they'd perhaps been considering suicide. And then when they read about the horrific impact on the people left behind, they've perhaps started to think about alternative things that they can do. And that is really powerful. So that's another group of people that would greatly benefit from reading my book. But yeah, parents like me who have had to struggle with their own personal loss, but also the loss of their children and how to deal with that and the things I've got wrong that didn't work or the things that I've learned that really have worked and the place we're in now and just that message that it's hell
一段困难时期，他们可能曾考虑过自杀。当他们读到这对留下来的人造成的可怕影响时，他们可能开始思考可以做的其他选择。这非常有力量。所以这是另一群会从阅读我的书中受益匪浅的人。但是的，像我这样不得不应对个人损失，以及应对孩子们的损失，以及如何处理这些问题，我做错了什么、什么没起作用，或者我学到了什么真正起作用的东西，以及我们现在所处的境地，还有那个信息——这简直是地狱，
and you will go through the worst times and we had Covid to deal with as well in amongst all of that but there's hope and I remember one line in particular that I've included my book from a therapist that I saw once and I will never forget those words and I hope that my book does something similar for at least one person and carries some hope for them until a time where they can they can actually feel it themselves. Absolutely such powerful words and is it available on Amazon? It will be available on Amazon at the beginning of October. My intention is to publish it on World Mental Health Day, which is the 10th of October. I do have a website where I've got some free chapters available to have a read of now, though, so you can get an idea of whether it's something you want to know more about um great what's your website uh it's daddy blackbird www.daddyblackbird.com amazing thank you so much for your time and sort of throughout our discussion
你会经历最糟糕的时刻，我们还要应对新冠疫情，但希望依然存在。我特别记得我书中包含的一位治疗师说过的一句话，我永远不会忘记那些话，我希望我的书能为至少一个人做同样的事情，并为他们带来一些希望，直到他们自己能真正感受到希望的那一天。绝对是如此有力的话语，它在亚马逊上有售吗？它将于10月初在亚马逊上架。我打算在10月10日世界精神卫生日出版它。不过，我确实有一个网站，上面有一些免费章节可以阅读，所以你可以了解一下这是否是你想要了解更多内容的东西。太棒了，你的网站是什么？是daddy blackbird，www.daddyblackbird.com。太棒了，非常感谢你的时间，在我们的讨论中，
there's been lots of different themes and the one that we've kind of alluded to but not mentioned is anger you know and i think that came through quite strongly when you were talking about Daddy Blackbird hopping about the garden and anger is a such a normal part of the grief process but I think with with suicide it can really feel amplified as well and then you can feel kind of very conflicted for feeling feeling anger towards somebody that's died but anger is a very important human emotion and it's understandable that we would be feeling that. Absolutely, anger is something that I've felt from day one particularly when I see how sad my children are and when I'm struggling in the middle of the night with a
有很多不同的主题，我们提到过但没有明确讨论的一个是愤怒。我认为当你谈论“黑鸟爸爸”在花园里跳来跳去时，这一点表现得很强烈。愤怒是悲伤过程中非常正常的一部分，但我认为对于自杀，这种感觉可能会被放大。然后你会因为对一个已经去世的人感到愤怒而感到非常矛盾，但愤怒是一种非常重要的人类情感，我们感到愤怒是可以理解的。绝对是这样，从第一天起我就感受到了愤怒，特别是当我看到我的孩子们有多难过，以及我在半夜独自一人照顾
poorly child on my own or there are moments where Steve should be there and isn't and I'm angry because he didn't share with me his issues and challenges that led him to where he was I'm angry for this sense of abandonment that I feel for me and for my children. There's so many reasons why I'm angry and the anger has led me to some very dark places over time and some very unhealthy habits as well which have not worked well for me and again I've come out the other side of those and hopefully others can learn from those too. But yeah, anger is still a part of my life, much less so than it was before. My children don't seem to come across angry in any way. And I'm very grateful for that so I try to keep my anger away from them as
生病的孩子时，或者在Steve本该在场却不在的时刻。我很生气，因为他没有与我分享导致他陷入困境的问题和挑战。我为自己和孩子们感到的这种被遗弃感而愤怒。我愤怒的原因有很多，随着时间的推移，愤怒把我带到了一些非常黑暗的地方，也养成了一些非常不健康的习惯，这些习惯对我来说并不奏效。同样，我已经从那些习惯中走了出来，希望其他人也能从中吸取教训。但是的，愤怒仍然是我生活的一部分，尽管比以前少多了。我的孩子们似乎并没有表现出任何愤怒。对此我非常感激，所以我尽量让我的愤怒远离她们，
much as possible I'll let them see it occasionally because I think it's right that they do and I don't want to kind of hide things and lie about things but there's um there's certain elements of my anger that they don't need to see um and there's yeah there's a funny a funny moment where I'd I'd written um a lot about my anger there's a lot in my book about my anger and how that's changed over time but I wrote about how when I first saw this black bird and I could see how it was free and it was kind of liberated from any any kind of restrictions in life and that that's maybe how I saw Steve now and I think there was a moment where the house was a mess and I was knackered and I was fed up and the girls were having a bad day and I saw the blackbird turn
尽可能多地。我会偶尔让她们看到，因为我认为这样做是对的，我不想隐瞒或撒谎。但有些……有些我愤怒的元素是她们不需要看到的。有一个有趣的时刻，我写了很多关于我愤怒的内容，书中有很多关于我的愤怒以及它如何随时间改变的内容。但我写到当我第一次看到这只黑鸟时，我能看到它是多么自由，它从生活中任何限制中解脱出来，也许这就是我现在看待Steve的方式。我想有一次家里一团糟，我累坏了，我很沮丧，孩子们那天过得很糟糕，我看到黑鸟出现，
up and I had some really dark thoughts about what I wanted to do to this blackbird and I wrote that in my book and when it was being edited by my proofreader he said whoa you can't say that um so he he helped me filter that down to more appropriate language um around how I felt about the blackbird but yeah it has it has softened over time I've learned more about how I need to understand the place Steve was in I've learned more about suicide and how it changes the way people feel and how mental health can impact people in such different ways which I didn't know anything about before so yeah anger has been massive and I actually shared the manuscript with somebody just like me who'd lost a husband to suicide when she had two young children not that long ago. And she read my manuscript and gave me some amazing feedback on it recently. And the biggest
我产生了一些非常黑暗的想法，关于我想对这只黑鸟做什么。我把它写进了书里，当我的校对员编辑它时，他说：“哇，你不能那样说。”所以他帮我把语言过滤得更得体，表达我对这只黑鸟的感受。但随着时间的推移，它确实软化了。我学到了更多关于我需要理解Steve所处境地的知识，我学到了更多关于自杀以及它如何改变人们的感受，以及心理健康如何以如此不同的方式影响人们，这些是我以前一无所知的。所以是的，愤怒的影响是巨大的。我实际上与一个和我一样的人分享了手稿，她不久前在有两个年幼孩子的情况下失去了丈夫。她读了我的手稿，最近给了我一些很棒的反馈。最大的
point, other than things like she said, I can share it with my mum and she can now understand where I'm coming from but the biggest point was that she was nodding all the way through it when I talked about the anger and she'd never felt that she could show that anger or talk about it because there's so much sympathy for the person that's died and what a sad place they must have been in to get to that point that it feels inappropriate almost to talk about how you're angry with them and we don't want to blame them and we don't want to bring about shame but anger still exists because of the circumstances that we find ourselves in. It really does. And, you know, we think about anger as being a secondary emotion. So something else always comes first. And the fact
一点，除了她说我可以和妈妈分享，她现在能理解我的想法之外，最大的点是当我谈到愤怒时，她一直在点头。她从未觉得可以表现出这种愤怒或谈论它，因为人们对死者有太多的同情，认为他们一定处于多么悲伤的境地才会走到那一步，以至于谈论你对他们的愤怒似乎是不合适的。我们不想责怪他们，也不想带来羞耻感，但由于我们所处的环境，愤怒依然存在。确实如此。而且，我们认为愤怒是一种次要情绪。所以总有别的东西先出现。事实上，
that you're not seeing that in your girls at the moment, I think, again, reinforces what a great job you're doing at helping them recognise and discuss their primary emotions. So maybe they are feeling abandoned. Maybe they are feeling disappointed. Maybe they are feeling abandoned maybe they are feeling disappointed maybe they are feeling sad maybe they're feeling jealous of their peers who still have both parents and when we're able to properly tap into those primary emotions there's less need for the secondary emotions um and again just shows me what a great job you're doing i think that's really helpful though what you what you've said there and I think the the different emotions that you you've listed um are really I mean there's endless emotions that we can talk about but it's good to have a broader vocabulary of emotions that that you can help
你目前在你的女孩们身上没有看到这一点，我认为这再次强化了你在帮助她们识别和讨论主要情绪方面做得有多棒。所以也许她们感到被遗弃。也许她们感到失望。也许她们感到悲伤。也许她们嫉妒那些父母双全的同龄人。当我们能够正确地挖掘这些主要情绪时，对次要情绪的需求就会减少。这再次向我展示了你做得有多棒。我认为你所说的真的很有帮助，你列出的不同情绪……我的意思是我们可以谈论无穷无尽的情绪，但拥有更广泛的情绪词汇来帮助
children to to use because for me it's been sad and angry a lot of the time and I need to remind myself that there's a lot on that scale in between and and they need to know that too and like you say that that kind of maybe resentment towards friends who've got the most amazing dad and and they don't have that um and moments in the future when Steve isn't there to walk them down the aisle when they're getting married and those are moments where anger might appear or any of those other emotions and we're not out of the woods now and we never will be but by equipping ourselves with coping mechanisms to deal with all of these different emotions I'm hopeful that we've got a decent future ahead of us. I really, I feel so certain of that. It's been an absolute pleasure speaking with you.
孩子们使用是很好的。因为对我来说，很多时候是悲伤和愤怒，我需要提醒自己，在这两者之间还有很多其他情绪，她们也需要知道这一点。就像你说的，那种对拥有最棒爸爸的朋友的怨恨，而她们却没有……以及未来Steve无法在她们结婚时牵着她们走过红毯的时刻，这些都是愤怒或其他情绪可能出现的时刻。我们现在还没有走出困境，永远也不会。但通过装备自己应对所有这些不同情绪的应对机制，我希望我们有一个体面的未来。我真的，我对此感到非常确定。和你交谈真是太愉快了。
Keep doing what you're doing, both for the community, but for yourself and your girls. I can't wait to read Daddy Blackbird when it's available. And I will share that freely on my networks as well once it's published. But thank you so much for your time, Caroline. Thank you. I really appreciate the opportunity to talk about all of this and your lovely approach to listening and understanding. Well you're so welcome it's been an absolute pleasure and it's
继续做你正在做的事情，为了社区，也为了你自己和你的女孩们。我迫不及待地想在《黑鸟爸爸》出版后阅读它。一旦出版，我也会在我的网络上自由分享。但非常感谢你的时间，Caroline。谢谢。我非常感谢有机会谈论所有这些，以及你倾听和理解的可爱方式。不用客气，这绝对是一种荣幸，而且这是
such an important conversation to have and I'm hopeful that this episode will trickle through where it needs to, it will be listened to and watched by health professionals, but also by, by people who are interested in learning about this stuff and might be experiencing, you know, some of the stuff that you've been through too. Yes, thank you. I'm hopeful that it can help somebody well thank you just before we finish could you tell us where people can connect with you on socials Caroline yes absolutely um I talk frequently on LinkedIn so I can be found there I don't think there's many other Caroline Rudehouses around um so yeah I'd love to connect with people on LinkedIn. And my website again is www.daddyblackbird.com where you can connect with me there too. Thank you. Oh, what an incredibly powerful episode.
一个非常重要的对话。我希望这一集能传播到需要它的地方，被健康专业人士听到和看到，也被那些对学习这些东西感兴趣，并且可能正在经历你所经历过的一些事情的人听到。是的，谢谢。我希望它能帮助到某人。好的，谢谢。在我们结束之前，你能告诉我们人们可以在哪里在社交媒体上与你联系吗，Caroline？是的，绝对可以。我经常在LinkedIn上发言，所以可以在那里找到我。我想没有多少其他的Caroline Rudehouses了，所以我很乐意在LinkedIn上与人们联系。我的网站再次是www.daddyblackbird.com，你也可以在那里与我联系。谢谢。哦，多么令人难以置信的有力的一集。
What a real privilege it was to speak to Caroline. Please, if the conversations we had today and the book, which is going to be published very soon does resonate with you do go and follow her on LinkedIn. If you have enjoyed this episode please do rate and review on Apple Podcasts. Please do subscribe on YouTube and follow the show on Spotify. Please also when thinking about grief do bear in mind one of my books The Grief Collective which gets lovely feedback on Amazon and And if you have read that already, I would be so grateful if you consider rating and reviewing that on Amazon and or Goodreads. If you're an aspiring psychologist or mental health professional, please do check out the Aspiring Psychologist Collective book and the Clinical Psychologist
与Caroline交谈真是一种荣幸。请，如果今天我们的谈话以及即将出版的书能引起你的共鸣，请务必在LinkedIn上关注她。如果你喜欢这一集，请在Apple Podcasts上评分和评论。请在YouTube上订阅并关注Spotify上的节目。在思考悲伤时，也请记住我的书《悲伤集体》（The Grief Collective），它在亚马逊上获得了可爱的反馈。如果你已经读过那本书，如果你能考虑在亚马逊和/或Goodreads上评分和评论，我将不胜感激。如果你是一位有抱负的心理学家或心理健康专业人士，请查看《有抱负的心理学家集体》（Aspiring Psychologist Collective）一书和《临床心理学家》
Collective book. And if you're looking for qualified mental health therapy, please do consider Talking Heads, your guide to finding a qualified therapist in the UK. If it's your time and you're ready for the next step in your psychology journey, please do consider joining us in the Aspiring Psychologist membership, which you can do for just £30 a month with no minimum term. And please do come along and join my free Facebook group, The Aspiring Psychologist Community, which is the exclusive home of Marianne's motivation and mindset weekly videos. Come and follow me on socials. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent everywhere. And if you have any ideas for future episodes
集体一书。如果你正在寻找合格的心理健康治疗，请考虑Talking Heads，这是你在英国寻找合格治疗师的指南。如果时机成熟，你准备好迈出心理学之旅的下一步，请考虑加入我们的“有抱负的心理学家会员”，每月只需30英镑，没有最低期限。请加入我的免费Facebook群组“有抱负的心理学家社区”，这是Marianne励志和思维每周视频的独家主页。来社交媒体上关注我。我到处都是Dr. Marianne Trent。如果你对未来的剧集有任何想法
or future special series, please do let me know. Thank you so much for being part of my world and i will see you very soon the next episode is available from 10 a.m on youtube on saturdays and from 6 a.m on mondays wherever you get your podcast take care if you're looking to become a psychologist then let this be your guide with this podcast at your side you'll be on your way to being qualified it's the aspiring psychologist
或未来的特别系列，请告诉我。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分，我们很快再见。下一集将于周六上午10点在YouTube上发布，周一上午6点在你获取播客的任何地方发布。如果你想成为一名心理学家，让这成为你的指南，有这个播客在身边，你将走上获得资格的道路，这是《有抱负的心理学家》
with dr marianne my name's yana and i'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner i read the clinical psychologist collective book i found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist it just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
与Dr. Marianne。我叫Yana，我是一名心理健康实习医生。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书，我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。我惊讶于有这么多不同的途径可以达到目标，没有完美的途径可以成为一名心理学家，这让我充满了信心，不，我没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，这会让你安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦开始读，你就放不下这本书了。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。